My name is Travis
Gerke, and I'm
the director of data science
at PCCTC, a clinical research
organization facilitating
clinical trials in the cancer
space.
I used to be an
academic and when
I was transitioning
to industry roles,
I found challenges in
refactoring my resume
and professional portfolio to
align with industry standards.
I hope to share some
resources that you'll
find useful in this talk,
What they forgot to teach you
about industry transitions
from academia. Or, more
simply, WTF AITA.
If you're not familiar
with these two acronyms,
we'll consider each in turn.
First, if in the
context of your job
you've ever asked what the [bleep]?
I'd probably respond
with great question,
particularly if you
are an academic.
This plot shows
one aspect of what
the [bleep]-ery in academia, the
increasing number of PhDs
awarded versus the much
smaller number of faculty jobs
available.
The gap between these
two diverging numbers
has helpfully
been labeled WTF.
There are lots of other reasons.
One might ask what the [bleep]
in academia,
but this is not really
a talk about that.
I would instead refer you
to the so-called quit lit
where people have discussed
their thoughts and experiences
on leaving academia in a variety
of formats, such as blogs
and social media posts.
Indeed, academia can be
a highly rewarding career
if it's what you
want, and this talk
is not at all focused on
criticizing that career choice.
All the same,
many academics are
currently industry curious,
and I hope that many
who are not in academia
will still find useful
content in this talk.
Academics certainly
don't hold the monopoly
on asking what the [bleep].
The second acronym,
AITA, stands for.
Am I the asshole?
This happens a lot
when academics first
apply to industry roles.
As a specific example, I
was asking this question
when my first job
applications to industry roles
received no response.
I thought, am I not qualified?
Are they the asshole?
Am I the asshole?
In this talk, we'll focus
on three common ways
that academics can
unintentionally be the hole.
The first, resumes that are
way too long are common.
Second, cover letters
should not be
a thesis on the direction
of your research,
rather a clear and focused
statement of your value
that is aesthetically
streamlined. And last,
an untidy coding portfolio
can make it very difficult
to see how the first
two items come together
to make you amazing.
In short, avoiding
[bleep]hole-ery really
means not asking others
to work hard to discover
how awesome you really are.
As a current reviewer of
many application packages,
I see some truly excellent,
excellent candidates
who could shine that much
brighter with some finesse.
Fortunately, the R
community has created
resources which make each of the
three problems easily solvable.
First, let's look at resumes.
Here, quite embarrassingly,
is the 22 page
resume that I sent as it
is to the first industry
roles to which I applied.
This beast served
me well in academia
where CVs are required
to be formatted
like this. In industry,
however, yes, I was the asshole.
Here, on the other hand,
is a stellar resume
that I received about a year ago
from someone a lot of you probably
recognize this at this conf.
Shannon Pileggi.
This elegant, elegant
two pager gives me
an easily accessible view of
Shannon's skills, experience
and clear links to
her portfolio, a topic
that we'll discuss later.
I'm lucky enough to
work with Shannon now,
and she gave me permission
to use this as an example.
The same goes for any examples
I'll show in this talk.
I either have permission
from the content owner
or it's publicly available.
If you want your resume
to look like Shannon's,
fortunately, there is an
R package for that.
It's called datadrivencv.
I won't repeat any
of the how to content
that the package
author Nick Strayer
has carefully assembled.
If you go to the
package vignette,
you should be up and
running in under an hour.
Aside from making a resume
that looks really slick,
there's a big bonus with
using a package like this
that I want to mention.
When hiring managers
like myself get
a stack of 50 to 100 resumes,
I can recognize right away
those applicants that use R
to create their materials.
This practice sends
a signal that you're
excited about integrating
R based workflows into all
of your activities, not
just those that involve
statistics or data analysis.
And it's a sure thing that I'll
read those resumes carefully.
Something else that the
datadrivencv package
does that's nice
is that it makes
it easy to include
or omit information
for long or short
versions of your resume.
For instance, if you still
need a long academic variation
for some purposes,
you can render
with all the publications and
fluff into dozens of pages.
And then, if you want
the industry ready
two pager, a quick filter
within datadrivencv
will get you there.
This eases some of
the pain I experienced
in moving the currency of
academia, pages
and pages of publications,
to a single bullet
point in my resume.
Next, let's discuss
cover letters.
Much like my
horrific academic CV,
I was also sending out this
dense research statement
as a generic cover letter.
Here, instead, is a template,
which is easy on the eyes
through generous use of white
space, is succinct at one page,
and even makes use of bullet
points to highlight key ideas.
Recall the signal
sending I mentioned
about resumes clearly built
with R. The same is true here.
I right away recognize
this as R Markdown
or LaTeX rendered due to general
font and alignment structure.
A dead giveaway is the
appearance of AwesomeFont
icons in the top right.
That typically doesn't
happen by accident
in a Word doc.
If you want to render
letters like this,
here's the stevetemplates R
package from Steven V Miller.
Making one of these is as
easy as installing the package
and creating a new Markdown file
from template in the RStudio
menu.
But cover letters
aren't the only thing
you're allowed to send as part
of your application package.
Let's have a look at something
really cool in the category
that I'll call
cover accessories.
In a recent RStudio
data science hangout,
which is an awesome community
resource that I'll describe
later, I met Javier Orraca.
He described his
recent application
to bloomreach, in which he
went way above and beyond
and made a bloomreach Shiny app
with some simulated data that
is themed with their org's
color scheme and logo.
The bloomreach team was, of
course, totally blown away
and Javier landed the job.
His technique of
demonstrating what's possible
is Shiny as a business
intelligence tool,
along with his mastery of
developing in it was spot on.
If you're interested in
the secret sauce
here, it's two packages
used inside of Shiny,
bslib and thematic.
I'll mention that, if you're
not a Shiny developer
and the idea of integrating
these components into Shiny
isn't something you want
to tackle right now,
don't forget that you can use
these same principles, namely
organizational
theming and showcasing
your R skills within a
standard R Markdown document
that is rendered to HTML or PDF.
Now, for portfolios.
Here's a common look for an
academic coding portfolio.
And yes, this page is
intentionally left blank.
Academia doesn't incentivize
maintaining this sort of thing,
but it's hugely
helpful in showcasing
your technical skills
for industry employers.
I'm going to show three
levels of portfolios
with increasing complexity.
Only one is really
necessary, but it's certainly
possible to have all three.
First not only is GitHub
the standard place
to deposit your projects
and code for public viewing,
the site also allows you to
put together a personal profile
on your landing page.
Here's a great example
for Monica Powell,
and her link, here, shows you how
to create this using the GitHub
interface. Here, though,
we're going to see
how you can do it in RStudio.
Conveniently, it's just
three lines of code.
The steps are this,
create an RStudio
project with the same name as
your GitHub user ID,
connect it to GitHub, and create
an R Markdown document that
renders to GitHub
compliant Markdown.
Again, these three
lines of usethis code
achieve these three
tasks directly.
Mash the knit button in RStudio,
push to GitHub, and you're done.
Any modifications
you'd like to make
are just done with
R Markdown syntax
that you probably already know.
Standard R plots and
all the bells and whistles
work here. As a
super basic example,
here's what happened
when I simply rendered
the usethis RMD default
document through this method
and pushed it to my GitHub
repository named my user
ID, tgerke.
Cool, right?
While we're on the
topic of GitHub,
I want to emphasize that
you should use and organize
your pinned repositories that
appear at the top of your page.
If you've done a solid job on
the resume and cover materials
that we discussed,
it's a virtual lock
that your GitHub profile
will be looked at.
Put good code that
you're proud of there.
If it doesn't yet have good
documentation or comments,
add them now.
Yes the very
careful reader might
be able to tell that you
added them after the fact,
but I claim that this
is not a big deal.
Adding them will show
that you understand
the importance of
well documented code
and that you can produce it.
Taking this all up a notch.
Here's our friend Hadley's
landing page at his website.
Looks awesome.
The great news is that
you too can be Hadley.
This is made with Sean Kross'
excellent postcard package
postcards package.
Hadley used the trestles
template, but there are other
great looking options here if
you want to branch out a bit.
Getting started
is made very easy
with the help of the package
vignette, which is linked here.
Now here in expert mode.
You can develop a
full blown website
with a blog using RStudio,
like Alison Hill has been
doing elegantly for years now.
Her most recent iteration uses
Hugo Apero through blogdown,
which she will
carefully walk you
through in detail in the
linked recording of her
R Ladies talk from last year.
blogdown with Hugo
is one way to do it,
but other popular options
include distill and Quarto.
Danielle Navarro has
superb examples
of both in the form
of a quarto blog
that was migrated from distill.
She describes each
of those formats
and how you develop
in each at her blog
post, which is linked here.
When it comes time to publish
your content on the web,
don't forget that you can
use free services from GitHub
pages and Netlify.
There's no need to purchase a
dedicated domain name if you're
not ready for that yet.
Overlaying all the
topics we discussed
is the incredible R community.
If you ever need support,
want to discover who is hiring,
or generally get connected
with amazing people,
here are some directions
I would suggest.
I'll link from this page.
In order,
Rachael Dempsey runs
a virtual weekly
RStudio data science hangout
with data science leaders
and community members.
This informal
get together
is an excellent way
to stay in touch
and find out what's new in
the R and data science world.
Tighty Tuesday is
both a podcast run
by Jon Harmon and a highly
engaged weekly community
activity run by Thomas Mock.
It's a great way to
hone your skills,
show off your data science
wizardry, and learn from others.
Tidy Tuesdays is one component
of a larger, very active R
for Data Science community.
This community
runs a Slack server
where you can ask and answer
technical questions or just
chat about data
science in general.
One very helpful channel
there is a jobs hiring
board where you'll see many
R specific jobs posted.
R user groups or
so-called RUGs
can be found nearly
anywhere in the world
these days. If there
isn't one close to you,
consider starting one.
The R Consortium
sponsors many of these
and will help you get started.
Back when I was in
Tampa, I started
one of these which
met monthly and I
met friends which I'm very
close with to this day.
Many job related connections
tend to happen at these events
as well.
In the same vein,
R Ladies Global
is a worldwide
organization that promotes
diversity in the R community.
Much like the RUG meetups,
you can probably find one of
these running in your area
and you should
definitely check it out.
Lastly, the RStudio community
has forums and job boards that
range from the technical
to community building
and is a great
place to hang out.
Final resource I'm
going to leave you with
is a compilation of
all the resources
we've discussed and more.
WTF-AITA.com is
a place where you
can find these slides and
links to the tools therein.
But this talk certainly
only represents
a slice of a much larger set
of guidance and resources
around industry job seeking.
Many of you in RStudio
community have already
traveled this road,
and if there are things
you'd like to see
represented on the site,
please do feel free to submit
an issue or a pull request
at the GitHub repository.
It's my intent that
the site organically
grow as a community
owned utility over time.
With that crowdsourcing
request in mind,
I'll now hand the discussion
off to the excellent RStudio
community.
Thanks so much for
having me at conf,
and I look forward to seeing
you in the Discord hallways
and answering any
questions that you may have
in this particular session.